MTF Agents scramble through the crowd of bloodthirsty,
hypnotized festival-goers.
Up on the stage, a pair of living statues
hold down a screaming man as they produce
medieval instruments of torture from an antique
case.
Maybe this time, the agents can stop it.
Maybe they can prevent all the horror and
bloodshed.
But one thing stands in their way: A man-sized,
cartoonish dove costume, flying down towards
them, wielding a large wooden mallet that
would only bring death and destruction.
Needless to say, even by Foundation standards,
this one is going to be weird…
When you found yourself sought out by the
SCP Foundation’s recruitment division and
offered a role in the research department,
they made sure to inform you of the risks.
After all, a workplace injury in this line
of work might be far more serious than slipping
on a wet floor, or developing carpal tunnel
from typing all day.
Working within the ranks of the Foundation,
you could be the unfortunate victim of any
number of dangerous anomalies, whether its
SCP-096 appearing behind you after you accidentally
caught a glimpse of it as a single pixel in
a photo.
Or if you were in the wrong place at the wrong
time whenever SCP-682 next broke out, then
chances are you’d be receiving an early
redundancy… and a closed casket service,
if there’s even enough of you left to bury.
It is the one thing you never want to happen.
The scenario you’re constantly warned about
from the moment you join the Foundation: a
containment breach.
Anything can be the cause of an anomaly breaking
free of containment and spreading untold chaos
in the process.
Whether it’s the result of a particularly
cantankerous SCP that doesn’t take kindly
to being locked up, an act of earnest human
error with disastrous consequences, or even
intentional sabotage enacted by a group of
interest trying to seize anomalies for their
own purposes.
There’s no telling when or where a containment
breach might occur… or is there?
Despite all the resources at their disposal
– specialized facilities spanning the globe,
advanced technology, and a nearly inexhaustible
supply of personnel to contain SCPs – the
Foundation still manages to suffer catastrophic
casualties as a result of containment breaches.
But surely, if they’re so well equipped,
such breaches should be almost impossible,
right?
Well, yes.
So, what causes them?
What if every containment breach, all the
loss of life, the further spread of anomalies,
and the destruction of Foundation of property
incurred, was all caused… by an SCP?
Not a living entity, mind you.
More some kind of latent anomalous phenomenon
that triggers containment breaches without
warning.
The prevailing theory surrounding this phenomenon
is even itself considered to be an SCP within
its own right, referred to as SCP-001.
Of course, as many of those well-versed in
the history and practises of the SCP Foundation
will already know, SCP-001 is a designation
shared by a number of anomalies.
Some are believed to actually exist, while
others are speculated to just be falsified
covers created to mask the real SCP-001.
From beings such as the Gate Guardian and
the Scarlet King, to the existence of God’s
Blind Spot and even the Foundation itself,
each of these SCP-001’s are nicknamed after
the Foundation researcher who proposed them
for the designation, and often considered
to be some of the first, if not the very first,
anomalies ever encountered – or at least,
documented.
In that regard, this SCP-001 – Plague’s
Proposal – could well be one of the very
first latent anomalies to exist, explaining
why so many SCPs were uncontained prior to
the Foundation being established, and why
even now, with all their resources, containment
breaches are still a worryingly frequent occurrence.
There are multiple anomalies that appear to
have been directly affected by SCP-001, at
least, according to the research of one of
the Foundation’s Directors, Director Lague.
While he might be drawing conclusions and
seeing patterns where there aren’t any to
speak of, Lague reasons that the circumstances
of these specific recorded containment breaches
seem to indicate that SCP-001 was at fault.
The first of these incidents Director Lague
focuses on in his research is also the one
we’ll be focusing on for the remainder of
this video.
It is designated as SCP-001-1.
SCP-001-1 previously went under the designation
of SCP-5770, and is an annual, anomalous event
that occurs in the Piazza della Signoria in
Florence, Italy.
The event consists of an unscheduled festival
that goes on for a period of ten days, wherein
anyone present within a ten-kilometer range
of the affected area suffers a mind-altering
effect that compels them to attend the festival.
However, SCP-001-1 is not a well-documented,
long-running festival of great cultural significance
to the people of Florence, neither is it an
event that is widely advertised.
Yet, those who have experienced the psychic
draw of this anomalous festival are driven
to attendance.
During the course of SCP-001-1, two anomalous
entities that resembled the statues created
by Michelangelo during the Renaissance will
host a show wherein they take to a stage to
judge people that they deem to be sinners.
This pair of statue creatures will call upon
the audience and bring those they’ve designated
sinners up onto the stage with them and will
then enact makeshift, grueling punishments.
These have been noted to resemble the acts
depicted in Dante Alighieri’s Inferno, so
if you ever need any further proof of how
hellish these punishments are, we recommend
asking an art expert.
The moment that SCP-001-1 ceases and the festival
comes to a close, any and all in attendance
are subject to yet another form of anomalous
mental alteration, and will proceed to instantly
forget the event.
Any of the horrific torture performed on stage
becomes unknown to those that directly witnessed
it, leaving them unaware of anything that
occurred only moments prior.
So, given the Foundation’s extensive knowledge
of this festival, its gruesome proceedings
and the effects it has on those in attendance,
you might be forgiven for expecting them to
have a fairly well-established method of keeping
the event contained.
Presumably, setting up a cordon to keep attendants
out of the area, administering amnestics to
any that might have been affected by SCP-001-1’s
anomalous mind-altering.
But then you remember SCP-001, the theory
behind what could be the cause of containment
breaches.
As a result, the Foundation has still been
unable to establish containment of the event
formerly known as SCP-5770, and Director Lague’s
research has tied this issue with containment
to SCP-001, hence the festival’s redesignation
to SCP-001-1.
Following the initial discovery of an anomalous
annual occurrence in the city of Florence
in 1985, the SCP Foundation’s head researcher
assigned to what was then known as SCP-5770
was one Joseph Pasqua, former Site Director
at Site 322.
Pasqua was, according to the incidents recorded
on the Foundation’s own database, somehow
manipulated by one of the anomalous statue
creatures that performed the show during occurrences
of SCP-5770.
It was thanks to the influence of this entity
that Joseph Pasqua deserted his post at the
Foundation, and went into hiding.
The fact that the influence of one of the
‘performers’ of this festival was able
to extend its influence to a senior member
of Foundation staff was not only troubling,
but also constituted a containment breach.
Pasqua would later be tracked down by Foundation
agents operating in and around Italy.
He was discovered thirty years after his desertion
in Vatican City, as a member of the Papal
Conclave – a specially selected group of
Catholic cardinals that are charged with electing
a new Pope.
If the former Site Director was still being
influenced by the statue creatures, it is
highly likely that he had spent the previous
three decades climbing the ranks of the Catholic
Church, potentially to install a new Pope
at the behest of the entities responsible
for conducting the torture of the Florence
festival.
Another recorded incident of a containment
breach surrounding the event, that seemed
to lend credence to the existence of SCP-001,
the anomalous cause of breaches, occurred
the year following SCP-5770’s discovery.
In 1986, the Foundation was observing the
proceedings of the festival as part of their
ongoing investigation into its bizarre nature.
On site were agents of Mobile Task Force Zeta
66, better known under their unit’s codename
of the ‘Guardian Angels.’
During the festival, MTF Zeta 66 operatives
noticed the presence of a previously unknown
entity associated with the anomalous event.
The Foundation was already aware of the pair
of seemingly living Michelangelo sculptures,
designating them as SCP-5770-1 and SCP-5770-2
respectively.
This third entity, despite being given the
designation SCP-5770-3, had its own preferred
identification for itself.
The being referred to itself as ‘God’s
Strongest Soldier’ and resembled a mascot
costume of a dove.
Approximately two meters tall, this creature’s
body was entirely hollow – there was nothing
within the costume, the costume was its body.
The responding agent of MTF Zeta 66, codenamed
Zeta Turquoise, was the first to confront
God’s Strongest Soldier, and was greeted
with quite the opener.
“Tweedley-dee, tweedley-da.
God’s strongest soldier is my name.
Getting rid of sin is my game.”
Confused at the creature’s demeanor and
presence, Zeta Turquoise called in a report
to command, stating that a large bird man
was harassing random attendants of the festival.
When Turquoise moved in to confront SCP-5770-3,
the creature repeated its assertion that it
was God’s Strongest Soldier, and that its
aim was to get people into heaven.
The Agent requested that God’s Strongest
Soldier get out of his way, he had a job to
do, but the bizarre bird-man responded with
more whimsical nonsense.
“Burgers, sandwich, fruit, and fries, you
just told me a big, fat lie!”
God’s Strongest Soldier proclaimed.
“Tweedley deedopa, didapa di dowop, papa-doda!”
Upon Zeta Turquoise attempting to push past
the creature, SCP-5770-3 produced an oversized
wooden mallet seemingly from out of thin air.
It then wound its arms back and immediately,
viciously struck the MTF agent.
A low-orbit Foundation satellite reported
not long after that an object had been detected
existing the Earth’s stratosphere.
Analysis confirmed it was, indeed, Zeta Turquoise.
Yes, he was literally punted into earth’s
orbit by a cartoonishly large wooden mallet.
As for the entity known as God’s Strongest
Soldier, the bird-like creature then proceeded
to attack the other members of Mobile Task
Force Zeta 66 in a similar fashion, making
sure they got to heaven in every sense of
the phrase.
With multiple recorded instances of containment
breaches occurring in relation to the festival
in Florence, and happening so frequently,
more and more evidence of Director Lague’s
theory about SCP-001 was being validated.
In 1988 the Foundation attempted a different,
more pacifistic approach to containing the
annual ‘celebration’, by attempting to
cordon off the entrance to the area of Florence
where those compelled to attend the festival
usually congregated.
There was additionally a cover story issued
to the public, stating that this was done
as a quarantine measure to keep residents
away from an area hosting a potentially dangerous
infection.
For a time, this seemed to be working.
The streets were quiet, local residents seemed
to be going about their business and paying
little mind to the Foundation operative in
the area.
That is, until the mind-altering effects of
SCP-001-1 took hold.
A mass of people, estimated to be over one
hundred thousand Florentines, charged towards
the cordoned-off area.
This mass of people swept through like a tidal
wave breaking through a dam, causing Foundation
personnel to be trampled alive.
Those that survived the initial rush were
attacked by civilians, in what seemed to be
a coordinated effort to reach the gathering
area for the festival.
All Foundation agents in the area were terminated
in short order, mercilessly slaughtered and
then cannibalized before anything that remained
of their bodies was dumped into the Arno River
nearby.
As well as being evidence of the sheer mental
alteration the statue creatures and the festival
itself were capable of, for Director Lague,
this seemed to indicate something further.
If an anomaly, SCP-001, was truly responsible
for all containment breaches, allowing them
to occur in spite of the measures taken to
prevent such things happening, then the phenomena
seemed to be occurring specifically to prevent
the Foundation from achieving containment
of certain SCPs.
Lague’s theory developed with every passing
breach that involved SCP-001-1.
In theory, the festival should have been an
average Tuesday for Foundation staff, a relative
walk in the park in order to contain it, if
not to outright stop it from happening at
all.
Yet, despite all their resources, manpower,
and expertise in all things anomalous, the
Foundation had been thwarted at every turn.
Despite how illogical such occurrences seemed,
containment breaches were still occurring
at an alarming rate, and perhaps none more
so than in relation to SCP-001-1.
The following year, 1989, brought with it
the most inexplicable breach yet, and further
proof for Director Lague’s theory about
SCP-001.
While the previous breaches were undoubtedly
anomalous in nature, each always carried with
it the possibility that somehow, despite the
low odds, the Foundation missed something.
Some human error or previously undiscovered
information about the festival could have
led to Pasqua’s alteration, or the arrival
of God’s Strongest Soldier.
But this time, it was undeniable that a force
beyond the scope of the Foundation’s understanding
was altering reality to prevent them from
containing the festival in Florence.
An invisible barrier manifested at every entry
point to the main area of the anomalous event,
whenever a member of Foundation personnel
tried to get in on foot.
Those that attempted to access the festival
area via rappelling out of helicopters instantly
caught ablaze and burned to death the moment
they touched down on the ground.
Any helicopter transports also crashed on
their return journey to Site 322, and God’s
Strongest Soldier was seen trampling on the
wreckage, before flapping its arms and flying
away.
It was following this incident that Lague
was promoted to the potion of Site Director
for Site 322, as a replacement for Joseph
Pasqua, who was still missing at this time.
The newly-appointed Director was yet to devise
his theory that there existed an anomalous
cause for all containment breaches.
However, during his introductory briefing,
he was presented with the file regarding SCP-5770,
and the various examples of it not being uncontainable,
but being very good at not being contained.
Director Lague asked if some of the more standard
methods had been attempted; at this point,
the Foundation had tried aerial bombardments
of the festival, Scranton Reality Anchors
to counteract whatever anomalous force was
preventing containment, even using SCP-682
to clear the area.
It had all failed.
Figuring out why was now Director Lague’s
job.
All the information of previous failed attempts
to contain the festival led Lague to the conclusion
that SCP-001 must exist.
An unseen phenomenon, the missing piece of
the puzzle, the element specifically interfering
with the Foundation’s efforts.
He presented his proposal to the Overseer
Council, who were skeptical, to say the least.
They posited that the statues and bird mascot
creature might be smarter than the latter’s
outwardly cartoonish nature portrayed.
But this is exactly what, to Director Lague,
indicated SCP-001 was responsible.
He explained that all in attendance at the
SCP-5770 festival took the event seriously.
But the appearance of God’s Strongest Soldier
was an abnormality, whose demeanor and tone
were drastically different from the rest of
the rather cutthroat proceedings.
Director Lague explained that the sheer absurdity
of this creature seemed to be the result of
SCP-001 interfering with their operations.
After all, if some other cause was to blame
– like an unknown cult attacking Foundation
personnel when they attempted to contain the
festival – then there would be evidence
of that, and Lague would have no reason to
suspect that God’s Strongest Soldier was
anything more than just a tonally dissonant
part of the festival.
Of course, Director Lague couldn’t prove
the existence of SCP-001 based on the presence
of one cartoonish bird mascot at a festival.
But before long, more and more breaches would
start occurring that seemed to further prove
that Lague was on to something.
There was something else at work, causing
containment breaches that put the entirety
of the Foundation in jeopardy…
Now check out “SCP-001 WHEN DAY BREAKS”
and “SCP-001 WHICH IS THE REAL 001?”
for more!